we have nine balls right over here and
we're going to assume that they look
completely identical but one of the
balls is slightly heavier than the other
eight and you can't tell it just by
feeling it's very slightly heavier you
would need some type of an instrument to
tell which what whether the ball one one
ball is heavier than another ball and
the only instrument that you have at
your disposal is this scale right over
here and so my question is using this
scale using this scale what is the
minimum number of times that you need to
use it in order to figure out what that
which of these nine balls is the heavy
ball and so I encourage you to pause
this video and think about it as long as
necessary to think what what is the
minimum times that you need to use this
scale and then when you unpause I will
give you a few hints so I'm assuming
you've given a try at it and maybe
you've been able to do it in in three
time or three three wings of or using
the scale but I will now tell you that
it is possible to do it in two Wang's so
if you didn't figure out a way to do it
in two Wang's I encourage you to pause
the video again and try to figure out a
way to do it in two Wang's so once again
I assume you've given a go at it for the
two Wang's and now I will give you a
hint
you might have figured it out in which
case congratulations but in case you
didn't figure out I'll give you a hint
each time you use the scale you can rule
out two-thirds of the balls so think
about that the first time you use it you
can rule out two-thirds of the balls so
you'll have three left and the second
time you use it you could rule out
two-thirds of the three left and you'll
have one ball left which you know will
be the heavier ball so if that gets you
excited that now you can solve it once
again pause the video and try to solve
the problem so I'm assuming you've had a
go at it and maybe you solved it maybe
you haven't but now let's work through
it together and just like I said in each
weighing we figure that we can rule out
two-thirds of the balls so how do we do
that well step one
step one let's--we three balls versus
three balls so let's say you take this
group right over here and you put it on
that side of the scale and then you take
this group right over here these three
right over here and you put it on that
side of the scale so how does that help
us well there's two possible outcomes
over here one possible outcome is that
you have balanced that they are the same
that they balance and then the other
outcome is that one side is heavier one
side is heavier so what can you deduce
if they are the same well if they are
the same then you know that this group
must have the heavy ball so if you know
that this group has the heavy ball then
what you do is out of this group you put
one of the balls you put one of the
balls on that side
one of the balls on that side so let me
put it this way then you weh-weh other
other group and you do that by doing one
versus one and then those are either
going to be the same and if they are the
same say these two are the ones you
weigh and they are the same then you
know that this one must be the heavier
one so then that one then you know the
other other is heavier now if you vit
weigh one versus one and let's say this
one is heavier than this one then you
know that this is the heavy ball or if
you know that this is heavier than this
then you know this is the heavy ball so
otherwise you obviously know the heavy
ball whichever one goes down is heavier
heavy heavy ball and you follow the same
logic right over here if when you
weighed these this group of three to the
compared to this group of three and you
saw that one side is heavier then you do
the same exercise with the heavier side
so let's say let's say you determine
that this side is heavier then out of
this side you do one versus one so you
may put that there and then
there so then you do so you do one
versus one from heavy side from the
heavy side and it's the same logic if
these two are the same then this is
going to be the heavy ball if one of
these goes down and the other one goes
up then you know that that's the heavy
ball so if it's the same same then you
get the other one that you didn't weigh
as heavy is the heavy ball and if there
if if one of them goes down you know
that's the heavy ball
no heavy you know it's the heavy ball
and so this is just a general in support
in general you sometimes think oh if I
could only weigh two things at a time
how can I rule out two-thirds well I've
just told you and you can use this
principle so you can imagine how many
weighings would it take if you had 27
balls and I sure I think that's an
interesting thing to think about and
sometimes this is actually it's
something that shows up in a lot of
interview questions sometimes they won't
give you a group of 9 they'll give you a
group of 8 so let's say there was only 8
balls and one was heavier and they tend
to do that at least my my idea of what
my theory of why they do that is because
it's a little bit less obvious that you
would break it up into thirds then but
you could do the exact same thing so I
encourage you to think about two things
how would you how many wings would it
take if you had 27 balls one of which is
heavier and how would you do it if you
had a situation where you only had 8
balls and from that you can devise all
sorts of neat derivative brain teasers
from this one